thank you
hello can I help you
we work for the most successful mobile
game studio in Los Angeles but suddenly
CEO Scholars
and then he arrived
[Music]
so who's the suit he's a consultant
good morning comrades my job is to
observe to streamline
to improve
for those who work remotely you have one
hour to get here or you'll be terminated
inspiring Ian says he doesn't like the
way he smells bow your heads
and pray for him
how are you enjoying the gaming industry
how many of these patrons do you think
we could fight
for them and you could do the remaining
three
excuse me
there's literally nothing online about
it some other CEO hired Pat talking
a few weeks later what if he's more than
just a consultant what the hell stop the
car
you're breathing too fast now breathe
with me then
uh
we work for sociopath
some Excel under stress maybe he's just
really good at his job
some break
[Music]
Sky
he's not who he pretends to be
I won't be here forever I'm only the
consultant